los jugadores y el cuerpo técnico del
arma Fútbol Club presentaron sus
respetos a los fallecidos después de la
catástrofe del estadio canchuruano
tras la derrota del equipo 3 a 2 El
sábado se produjeron disturbios entre el
público y una estampida posterior cuando
la policía disparó gases lacrimógenos
contra los aficionados más de 120
personas murieron entre ellas al menos
32 niños sientas más resultaron heridas
tenemos la esperanza de que este
incidente se convierta en El Punto de
partida de una nueva era del fútbol
indonesio y mundial
detengan todo esto el resultado de un
partido no vale la vida de las personas
especialmente de más de un centenar de
ellas esto es inaceptable y está fuera
de toda razón
investigadores fueron enviados a maland
Java Oriental para determinar Cómo se
produjo el desastre se han suspendido
todos sus partidos de fútbol y se ha
prohibido a armar partido durante el
resto de la temporada el presidente del
equipo pidió disculpas y aseguró que su
equipo y el cooperan y apoyan la
investigación de lo ocurrido
yo como presidente de la arema Fútbol
Club estoy dispuesto a asumir toda la
responsabilidad por el incidente del 1
de octubre estamos dispuestos a dar una
compensación lo que sea a las víctimas
Aunque todo lo que hagamos no podrá
devolver a las víctimas
en las últimas décadas Indonesia ha
sufrido una serie de incidentes críticos
relacionados con el fútbol en los que el
hacinamiento y las son habituales pero
las autoridades también han sido
criticadas por su gestión de las
multitudes la FIFA organismo rector del
fútbol mundial prohíbe el uso de gases
lacrimógenos en los estadios por motivos
de seguridad pero la policía Indonesia
los utiliza con regularidad para
controlar las manifestaciones durante
partidos de fútbol